pro debates is back and he said we
should have they said
we should have reasonable restrictions
on guns you shouldn't be able to alter
guns to fire at a certain rate or have
ammo capacities that are extreme does
anyone remember the parkland shooting
there was a school resource officer
there the person with the gun didn't
save them parkland had someone with a
gun and it didn't stop the shooter what
about the recent school shooting where
when the cops got there they didn't stop
it it's almost like more guns doesn't
fix the problem and just a quick side
note 94 percent of mass shootings happen
at gun-free zones also 75 of mass
shootings happen with pistols
just a side note thomas from texas case
you didn't know that before you know it
now well we we pat did a long deep dive
on this and we did a bunch of research
for
what is the problem with guns and this
was just after uvalde and it was a lot
of information it's a good watch because
it is interesting to see there are
certain regulations that you can put in
place but the majority of these mass
shootings happen in gun-free zones and
not to mention the media deceive you
they say there's been 276 mass shootings
this year but what they don't go to tell
you is that a mass shooting is simply an
instance wherein four or more people are
shot
right it's not four or more people die
or what that's a massive murder right
it's just four or more people are shot
you could have 77 people shot and
they've all been shot in the toe and
they're gonna be fine right so it's just
it's misleading i think that that point
about uvalde and the law enforcement is
an important point which is that what
you saw unfold there was law enforcement
on the scene i mean it was just gross
negligence it was disgraceful actually
what went on there i i don't know what
the consequences have been for those
officers but they should be steep
so
again just because you have people armed
there that doesn't mean that they're
gonna write if they're standing in the
hallway they're afraid to go in right
that's a problem that's a huge problem
that needs to be addressed 100 and you
have oftentimes other issues that happen
like people who are repeat offenders
people who um should never have had
access to a gun to begin with because
there is mental illness in their file or
you can look back and then something
terrible happens and all of a sudden a
million people come out and say well i
knew that he was crazy because this
happened and i knew this but they don't
report it or there's not a coordinated
file that's kept on that person so of
course somebody with mental illness
should not be walking around legitimate
mental illness legitimate mental illness
and i know the slippery slope on that
too because think about government
making a decision as to who's mentally
ill
i'd be next because they don't like what
i say so there's that too
but
when you talk about capacities and stuff
what guns can and can't do you have to
always just remember something is that
the criminal on the street
or the person seeking to inflict harm
they don't have limitations on their
guns right they're not going to be like
well let me i'm going to go shoot up a
movie theater but i need to want to obey
the gun law let me make sure that i only
have this amount of magazine no they're
not doing that they're looking out to to
produce maximum harm
so when you limit those things
oftentimes you limit it for law abiding
people you don't limit it for the people
seeking to impose harm and then what
happens right like they always say why
do you need you know a semi-automatic
weapon to
defend your home and i say well
what about the single mom out living in
a rural area with you know she's got her
son in there and somebody comes with a
semi-automatic to her front door and
tries to kill her like why do you want
her weapon to be less than so and i'm
not a weapons expert like i said i'm ver
i bring people on to talk about this
stuff because i'm not a gun expert i've
shot guns but i don't i'm not somebody
who's really i didn't grow up with that
as part of my culture so if you want to
have somebody on to talk about that we
can i have a few people in mind who i
think would be fantastic to really talk
about
what's really going on um and what would
actually fix the problem i do believe
that certain regulations could be put on
the books but again i'm going to tell
you that
these people who who seek to destroy
they just don't they don't care about
any of this stuff they're going to do
what they did in canada and mass stab
people right or they're going to do what
they did in boston and blow the place up
and they're going to drive a car through
a parade like they're or they're going
to get the guns they're going to get
them anyway and they're going to get
them anyway the point is is i want it to
be an unfair fight if somebody's trying
to break into my home
i want it to be an unfair fight you bet
your ass i want to have six magazines
available i want to have 150 rounds
right i want to have a scope i want it
to be lit up i want to have body armor i
want to protect myself and my family i
don't want it to be a fair fight that's
right if somebody's stupid enough to
break in my home
like what do you want me to say oh
excuse me while i get my government of
you know government authorized my
government authorized mag magazine yeah
i'm out of ammunition give me a second
gotta change i can only put 10 rounds in
here and then what happens to you you
know and then the people who say and
oftentimes i think the people who say
these arguments like i've had many
conversations with new york city
liberals you go into a city like new
york and you hear sirens everywhere
there's this sense that the police
who
some people have an immense amount of
trust in
um
they're right there right there's this
sense that you pick up you call 9-1-1
and they're there right because you hear
them around you all the time
that's not how it is in large parts of
the country where there's you know
you've got your land and then you've got
a long drive to get to somebody else's
land and if you pick up the phone and
you call for law enforcement to show up
it takes them a while it's a very
different reality that it's very hard
for city dwellers to understand
so you have to a lot of the people who
are often making these cases
for second amendment rights are people
who don't have the luxury of feeling
that
police are so accessible all the time
um and by the way it is it's false it's
very false in those cities that's a
false sense because what happens in
cities like new york is the traffic it
becomes really hard for the cops to
actually get to you also you have
defunded police movements in those areas
police don't feel supported and police
just kind of
don't do their job a lot of times
truthfully because they don't want to
deal with the nightmare of the
bureaucracy so it's it's a false sense
of police readiness
um and and being able to be there right
at the scene right away it just doesn't
work like that even when you call an
ambulance in a place like manhattan it
can take a very long time they have to
weave in and out of a ton of traffic so
it's a false sense of security but it is
a sense of security that people have in
those cities nonetheless and they ranked
the top ten major cities chicago three
three and a half minutes los angeles six
minutes seattle seven minutes dallas
eight minutes miami eight minutes new
york nine minutes houston 10 minutes
what do you think can be done
not even right not even 10 minutes what
do you how much damage do you think can
be done in three and a half minutes
think about that think about new york
nine minutes nine minutes and that's
that's average right right so somebody
comes to your door
causing trouble
breaks the door in
you're there you've got kids you've got
you what do you you you let's say you're
lucky enough you get to room you close
the door behind you call the police
you're gonna
go now when this podcast ends go now and
sit quietly with nothing no phone
nothing
sit set an alarm for nine minutes
nine minutes and just put the phone
there and just sit it will be the
longest nine minutes of your life just
think about that time frame the next
time you make an argument that's like oh
just call the police a lot can happen in
nine minutes and you don't even want to
think about what that could be so
i think people's eyes are are
opening even in liberal cities um we had
kim iverson on the other day and she was
saying that even in los angeles
uh she had been hearing about a lot of
people during covid because the crime
was so bad that we're talking about
getting a gun who had never talked about
that before so it's you know people are
people's eyes are going to be open to
that more and more as time passes it's
just not a realistic position to take
that it's like oh just call the police
and wait out nine minutes
and think about if you're in a rural
please it could be 15 minutes you're
waiting for somebody to show up at your
door to offer help and who's to say
they're going to be able to provide help
no one's going to the other opinion
about this which is really important
is people feel like no one's going to
protect my family the way i would think
about you have kids out there is anyone
going to be as passionate to protect
your child as you are no it's just not
it's not going to happen if you like the
short clip you can catch another one
here or you can catch the full episode
right here